so thanks everyone for sticking around
and coming to this session I know cam
Davidson pee loon is speaking on
mistakes he's made and a lot of the
probabilistic type programming work he
does personally that's kind of where I'd
be right now so I'm flattered that all
of you are here so hopefully some you
still have room left in your brains
after the rest of this weekend no it's
the last talk of the weekend and I'm
pretty filled up conceptually at this
point so hopefully there's a little bit
of room left but if you don't have any
I'll forgive you I'm going to be talking
about the term data-driven and based on
this titles talk you can probably guess
I'm not the biggest fan of it but we'll
get a little bit more into that shortly
so I'm Greg Rita I'm a freelance data
scientists based in Chicago but I've
previously worked for a big consulting
accounting firm called PwC a small data
science consulting firm called datascope
which has greatly influenced this talk
and I've also spent three years at
grubhub where I did a lot of data work
there if you recognize that cartoonish
avatar you probably have used grubhub or
you've googled something pandas related
and wound up on my blog where I've
written some panas tutorials you can
find me online at all the usual places
I'm typically GJ Rita and i'll be
posting these slides there to my github
once I actually finished why finished
tweaking them shortly before this talk
so they're not up there yet so how many
of you would say your data driven in a
literal sense like you actually use data
to drive all your decisions or at least
would prefer if you could use data to
drive all of your decisions okay so a
couple of you I don't think I am or at
least I kind of hope I'm not I love data
don't get me wrong but I I don't like
that term I think being driven by data
alone is somewhat of a flawed approach
and hopefully by the end of this talk
you'll understand why I feel that way
and maybe even be nodding along a little
bit the nice thing about setting the
expectation that you might be looking
nodding along is that I won't be able to
tell whether you're knotting longer
nodding off to sleep so
either way I'm going to take it as a
compliment now that I've actually said
that so about the term it feels like
it's being used more and more and that
every company every organization whoever
it may be is kind of trying to one-up
each other at this point in terms of how
data-driven they can be but do we really
think this is a good idea to be driven
entirely by data I've been known to go
on my fair share rants Justin Andrew
over there can certainly attest to it
there my former co-workers and this is
one of the topics that's been known to
kind of kick one up with me it feels
like everyone's just trying to be
data-driven data-driven data-driven so I
think part of the culprit might be the
rise of this book and this term
Moneyball have any of you seen the Cena
movie or read the book ok a lot of you
for those of you that haven't seen it or
read the book please forgive the sports
ball references I'm about to make I know
a matt attack conference but I'm a
baseball fan and I think that this was
an extremely interesting book so even if
you're not a sports fan I would at least
recommend seeing the movie it's it's
kind of a cool story but to give you a
brief overview of it it tells the story
of the Oakland Athletics who are a major
league baseball team with perpetually
one of the lowest payrolls in baseball
and the thing with baseball is that
there's no salary cap which means that I
can spend however much money I want to
sign all the players i want this greatly
favors large market teams like the los
angeles dodgers that are the new york
yankees because they have larger fan
bases they live in higher economic areas
they bring in a lot more revenue than
the smaller market teams like the
oakland athletics or maybe the kansas
city royals to illustrate the point this
year the dodgers are spending more than
three times the amount of money that the
Oakland Athletics are so this but
despite all of this the A's kind of have
an interesting story and we're pretty
successful for a while my my argument is
that this is kind of partially to blame
it's probably the most i would say over
the past decade or so it's the most
well-known
kind of reference in terms of using
quantitative information to improve
things in popular culture so it's so
much so that sometimes you hear about
startups that you know we're over 4x
were uber for why well there's Moneyball
for sales Moneyball for government money
ball for bankers money were for golf you
there's even money ball four life and so
I think that it's kind of gone a little
bit too far but everyone who kind of is
familiar with this term and familiar
with the book of the movie takes away
that it was this battle of the scouts
versus the stat heads and what I'll get
into what kind of scouting is in a
little bit for those of you that aren't
familiar but yeah everyone takes away
that despite their tight budget the A's
were perennial contenders for much of
the early 2000s they made the playoffs
five times in a seven-year period that's
kind of unheard of given us given how
little money they were spending and they
did this by making use heavy use of
statistics and analytics to exploit
market inefficiencies so for example if
people are familiar with baseball you
get a base hit you go to first base
eventually you try to make your way
around the bases and you score a run
that's how you win games you score more
runs than you're out then the other than
the opponent but you can also walk and
if you take a walk it's the exact same
outcome as a hit you wind up on first
base well the metric that everyone's
always cared about historically is
batting average how good is a purse how
often does a person get a hit but
they're the A's phone that on-base
percentage which is hits plus walks plus
whether you get hit by a pitch is a but
is more highly correlated with winning
success than batting average it seems
like a very dog da moment right now get
that you know it's the exact same
outcome you wind up on first base but in
the early 90s and 2000s no one cared
about on-base percentage the A's were
the only team that actually realized how
valuable this was so they were signing
players that typically were far far more
expensive because they had great betting
averages but if they were getting on
base at a higher rate than other p
well what does it matter so the a's were
able to produce wins very cheaply what
everyone takes away from the story is
that the stat nerds were able to kind of
exploit these market inefficiencies to
kind of to further outcomes to better
the outcomes for the A's but what people
forget is that scouting traditional
evaluation of players via the naked eye
played an important role to and baseball
there's something called an aging curve
which is something that was that got
kind of developed through a lot of
research in the early 2000s baseball
players you can see by the curve this so
this is the agent curve for an offensive
player for a hitter and it kind of peeks
around their late 20s to early 30s and
then drops off greatly and this is so
this is runs above average so
essentially how good of a player how
much better than the average a player is
at a certain age so that it drops off
greatly and what end what has
historically what had historically been
happening was that you know teams a
player typically reaches free agency
after they've been in the major leagues
for six years if you over that time
you're typically paying them under their
wilkie contract Rookie contracts are
very cheap you drafted someone out of
high school you drafted amount of
college you're not paying them a ton of
money yet because you don't know they're
an established player so but so you have
them under contract for a period of time
and then eventually they probably hit
free agency around the age of the late
20s early 30s so a lot of these other
teams would then immediately go sign
away that player they go to the Yankees
and then go take a huge contract so
these young players are extremely
valuable so it's it makes sense to try
to find them early on in their career
take that risk and then you have them
under contract where they're producing a
great number they're producing very well
for a cheap cheap contract so an example
of this is to illustrate this point I'm
going to talk a little bit about Mike
Trout so he's an outfielder for the lot
for the Anaheim Angels he's 23 years old
old and he's in just his fourth season
in the major leagues and he he's in his
fourth season now he's already played
three full seasons within those three
seasons he's won already won the MVP
award and he's finished runner-up twice
he's universally regarded as the best
player in baseball however last year he
only made a million dollars and the year
before that he made the major league
minimum which is about five hundred
thousand dollars now if you compare that
to a great a great pitcher in baseball
Clayton Kershaw who is a well-known
established player Clayton Kershaw makes
33 million dollars this year which is
forty percent of the Oakland of the
Oakland A's total budget this year so
you begin to understand the importance
of drafting great players in a crow
acquiring them while they're still on
the rookie contract scouting is crucial
to this process because we don't we
can't we quantify the current
performance at the major league level
sure we could potentially try to do some
forecasting but there hasn't been a ton
of great work yet we're kind of reliant
upon the makeup of a player and
understanding how they might perform at
the buttery at the next level by seeing
things like their bat speed that how
quickly they run that sort of talent so
while everyone thinks that it was about
the scouts versus the stat heads the
reality was that it was through
quantitative analysis and qualitative
analysis by their scouting department
that they aides that the A's were able
to beat the odds stacked against them
and following their success most teams
across all sports have begun to adopt
the use of advanced statistics and
quantitative analysis whatever you want
to call it in some form so building on
top of each other's work they were able
to kind of produce better results they
weren't data-driven alone another
dichotomy that I've kind of seen happen
in in the past is the quads versus the
creative so maybe the data scientists
versus the designers an experience that
I've had with that was I was talking a
couple years ago but a company that was
with a company that was doing creative
type work Pixar type entertainment for
children's for children but on tablet
devices so you know you're carrying your
iPad around and your kid could
essentially watch
pics are like content but there was a
little button on the screen and if your
child pressed the button and talk to the
content the contact would respond and
kind of change so it would morph a
little bit with the cons with with what
your child was saying to it when I was
talking to the company about doing some
work with them they assumed that there
was automatically gonna be a conflict so
it was a small company time people and
they they have the assumption of I'm a
data person all i care about is data the
quantitative aspects of it they are
established in the entertainment field
and they know intuitively kind of they
have a good idea of what's going to work
they assume that there was going to be a
large fight between my approach to
working and they're kind of gut instinct
about about what actually works but in
reality we all kind of need to empathize
with our users and understand with them
and data aids in that understanding the
work I would have been doing would have
given them a better understanding of
what isn't isn't compelling content and
I think we have a lot we as data
scientists have a lot in common with
designers and other creative folk a
well-known pretty well-known design
consultant who does a lot of writing on
the topic Mike Montero recently wrote an
article called why you need design or he
recently wrote a book in within the book
there's a chapter called why you need
design and the design process he says is
the he said design is the process we
undertake to solve a problem now I've
never had a designer job title nor do I
think I ever will but this probably
sounds very similar to a lot of stuff we
do I think this comic can in some ways
kind of illustrate a pitfall we might
fall into this isn't actually XKCD this
is this is uh my friends at a company
called datascope so it says you know
it's the two data scientists talking to
one another and says we have this
awesome data on insert mouthwatering
description of data we cleaned it up and
we're running a sophisticated analysis
on it plus we expect to see story about
fascinating patterns isn't that cool and
the guy says Booya it sounds like so
much fun that you're doing why are you
doing that and you said well we're not
sure yet imagine the possibilities this
has to be valuable and then
the one data scientist kind of smacks
the other so I think we do this I think
we sometimes become fascinated by these
new shiny objects these new shiny tools
these new techniques but ultimately we
lose sight of the problem why are we
working on this what's it for what's the
problem we're solving the reality is
much like design data science is about
answering questions and solving problems
it's ultimately what it is at its core
would anyone disagree with that that's
shockingly no so it sounds a lot of like
Mike's quote earlier and while we might
not technically have the title of
designers I would actually argue that we
probably are designers how many of you
have a process that probably looks
pretty similar to this so there's
empathize define ID a prototype and test
does anyone kind of worked with this
approach no one all right we got reup
one person but so it goes by a lot of
names that you here agile scrum maybe
the dumbing wheel the concepts are all
similar this is the design process and
this is actually an image taken from
Stanford's design school now who
remembers the netflix prize does anyone
remember that a couple of you okay so
I'll talk a little bit about that and
maybe how the design process might have
impacted that so the netflix prize was i
think it was around 2006 netflix said
okay we're going to give a team you need
to improve our recommendation algorithm
by ten percent i think was reducing the
root mean squared error by ten percent
and people spent three years trying to
reach this goal ultimately you know you
saw quick gains and i think there was an
immediate reduction by about there was a
eight percent reduction i think within
the first six months of working on this
project and then four years everyone was
eating out trying to get the next
decimal point to ultimately get to ten
percent for the million dollars many
years later a team finally preached that
the ten percent gain however netflix
ultimately said well we can't use it and
instead they realized that if they were
to if they just created profiles with
accounts or they created profiles within
accounts which that improved their
recommendations
by the amount so ultimately they missed
the boat everyone needed to step back
from their solutions the fact that we
needed to improve the metric by ten
percent and really think about the
problem to define it the reality was
that many of the users were sharing
accounts which was muddying up the data
water so to speak so part of the
oversight was that they didn't really
start with the problem they were trying
to solve and said they started with the
solution that they wanted instead of
actually defining the problem and I have
a former coworker Mike stringer who used
to say e concrete with your goals so
Netflix set their goal here we want we
want a ten percent reduction and it's
good to be concrete with your goals but
state your problems in an ambiguous
manner so that you could know you leave
some openness some ambiguity to
understand the problem space and to
really define the problem space and now
to get into one final false dichotomy
that I think I see a lot is data science
versus user research we're generally
doing kind of quantitative research and
they're generally doing qualitative
research but it's it's is it really that
simple I think by this point in the talk
all of you kind of have an idea where
this is going it's a trap right the
there's this isn't some quantitative
research quantitative research or
qualitative research the reality is that
we should be doing both it's extremely
rare that we're so constrained that we
can only choose one or the other last
night I was googling user research
techniques and this is something that
came up now if you look at the landscape
of user research Mehsud methods over on
the Left we see kind of the behavioral
approaches right so in the more
qualitative ones ethnographic field
studies usability lab so sitting down
with users and actually watching them
work speaking to them while they're
having them think aloud while they're
kind of going through your product and
understanding what what they're feeling
and kind of what their issues might be
but look closely at that top right
corner there quantitative methods a be
testing can is being considered a user
research technique here and we'll come
back to that a little bit later but it
sounds already like we have a lot in
common with them most users I've worked
with
to live in the left half of this chart
the kind of the qualitative behavioral
methods all these techniques are great
but each of them suffer from their own
comment problem they're narrow so user
research studies they kind of there a
little bit narrow but they get deep user
research is great at many things
particularly a deep understanding of our
users their environment their behaviors
but the issue is that how many users can
we actually study in this deep manner 10
20 it takes a lot of time this won't
give us an understanding of all our
users but it allows us to generalize to
potentially even create personas about
our users similarly data science suffers
from their own problems they're just the
opposite as we've learned from talks on
spark desk and even Rob stories
fantastic data bike shed talk earlier
sample size generally isn't a problem
for us we can work with terabytes of
data without too much difficulty but
causality is hard data is great at
telling us many things who what where
when but the one thing that often can't
tell us is why our data doesn't speak to
us we generally have to speak for it and
we why is often the most important thing
we don't know why something's happening
why behavior is occurring and that's
important if we align ourselves properly
I think with our colleagues in user
research I think we're positioned well
to kind of create this nice feedback
loop allowing each of us to build off of
each other I'm terrible at illustration
so if I if I had had a scanner I
probably a hand drawn this but this was
the best I can do in Google draw I mean
ultimately we kind of have this data
scientist who can kind of look at
terabytes of data and end up saying well
I'm seeing this weird thing in the data
I don't understand why it's happening
maybe users are dropping off a page at a
certain point or they're struggling with
it with a login box or generally are
just slowly decrease low be moving away
from your product the repeat purchase
rate is going down over time we don't
really know why that's happening sure we
could potentially a/b test but that
inference is even also a little bit
difficult at times so we have to save
the user researcher do you have any
ideas how can we explore this and they
can kind of go do that they can provide
context
deep understanding the knowledge of why
something might be occurring by talking
to users by getting deep guiding a
in-depth understanding with them
similarly a user researcher can say well
I saw this weird behavior and a user
research interview but if you remember
there you can only probably talk to 10
20 people it's going to take a lot of
time for them to gather that information
so they come to us and they say well is
there data to quantify how often this
happens is this really a problem and I
think this is an important thing to
consider when working with our
colleagues in user research because in
reality our skill sets aren't
supplementary they're complementary
where data science falls short user
research excels Stephanie Kim gave a
great talk yesterday about using NLP
techniques to discover and measure
points of friction within your user base
and not only was an extremely practical
talk but I think it did a great job of
subtly communicating these points that
again they're not supplements their
complements now if you remember from the
user research landscape there was little
piece on a be testing so I want to talk
briefly about that does everyone here
know what a be testing is yeah no no
there's some time catching some knows so
a/b testing is kind of randomized
control experiments you have a
population of users you split them into
random segments and you give them two
different treatments where that tree
treatments may be a different type of
drug or a drug in a placebo or you show
them a different color button on each
webpage but because you have this
randomized control you can understand
did that impact did that cut that button
change actually impact the users
behavior did it get them to convert more
purchase more spend more money whatever
it may be but the problem is so it's a
technique to kind of optimize a given
metric but the problem is that is that
with a be testing you kind of hit this
drug after a while you hit this dreaded
local Optima so by kind of pairing
ourselves with user researchers and even
our co-workers in design and engineering
we can kind of get past this local
Optima I think and so I think it'd be
testing in some ways is akin to hell
climbing and computer science you know
there's kind of the Traveling Salesman
problem there's a little bit there's a
hill climbing problem of China optimize
and reach a global Maxima and if we're
driven by data alone it's a be testing
if we're just constantly trying to
optimize a given metric we're at risk of
hitting local Maxima because we don't
have a great understanding of where we
are on the overall landscape so if you
look at the image on the left side it's
our design it's the current existence of
our page say we're an e-commerce website
and you if we a be test we can climb up
the hill a little bit further and reach
that local local Maxima but eventually
it becomes difficult to kind of eke out
more gains and how do we have any idea
that we're actually at a local local
Maxima it's it's very tough for us to
figure that out so one solution is to
inject a bunch of randomness into kind
of into our algorithm so we jump around
randomly and essentially we move around
to new points on the map and we see if
that new if a new point is higher than
our than our current point and then if
it is well we start climbing further
from there creatives designers are our
randomness for our product to reach new
heights we'd have to take chances we
have to inject randomness into it if we
continue to optimize the same thing will
run out of hills decline out of hill to
climb we need to evaluate designs
holistically not just incremental
changes these new designs are kind of
jumping around the landscape there are
randomness and as we learn more about
the landscape and its topology we kind
of have a better chance of reaching that
global Maxima and so I think teamwork
makes the dreamwork by creating
multidisciplinary teams of data
scientists user researchers and
designers were able to better inform
everyone throughout the process to
create better experiences for our users
and reality if we think back to that
feedback loop it probably ends up
looking something like this now we have
the data scientists in the user
researcher working together creating
personas understanding in context for
the designers in the engineers designers
love this because it enables them to see
the world through personas through their
users eyes they're kind of like method
actors right and this is something that
Mike Montero who I showed the design
quote from
earlier this is something he advocates
for is that designers they're able to
kind of get into okay well if I
understand that the user is a woman aged
23 who's maybe purchasing something
while on the go it kind of helps them to
formulate how a design might have to
look how simple interactions might have
to be and so by doing this we kind of
were able to help them out with their
roles data points about their users
coupled with behaviors feelings deep
understandings from user research and
data scientists it even opens up the
potential for tailored experiences right
so if you have these personas why do we
take this one-size-fits-all approach we
could kind of tailor things to different
types of users and then you can feed
data back in to show different types of
treatments depending on which type of
user we think is it that's going to work
for and so I have a former coworker who
likes to refer to this as each of us
having our own superpowers how do any of
you actually remember this cartoon
captain planet captain planet in the
that's captain planet and his planet
ears and each of the planeteers had a
special natural resource power earth
wind fire water I'm forgetting other
ones but so I think this we're in kind
of a similar boat by combining our
skills with user researchers with
designers were able to kind of become
captain planet in the Planeteers this is
what we should be striving for for
better outcomes for everyone by working
collaboratively together so it's
important to remember that we're here to
make experiences not metrics even though
it's we're about answering questions and
solving problems the ultimate the
ultimate end to what our work is an
experience to a user not the
maximization of a metric and I think
Lorena talks a little bit about this
earlier this morning in her education
talk that we're optimizing for
experiences not metrics like parades and
tests and test scores and that learning
is a unique experience and we need to
tailor approaches to our audience to use
the available channels nessus to use the
available channels to communicate the
concepts to students so data is a
powerful thing it's extremely powerful
but we can't let it be
the only thing we consider when making
decisions if we do were destined to lose
sight of the big picture why we're doing
these things the problems were trying to
solve and the goals were setting out to
achieve and I'm kind of going to close
out here with a quote from nate silver
if any of you have haven't read his book
the signal and the noise I think it's a
an excellent read not everyone whether
they work with data or not should kind
of give it give it a once through and
the in the book Nate said this about
making a good forecast I think it
applies not only to forecast but all the
decisions we make that the key to making
a good fat forecast is not in limiting
yourself to quiet quantitative
information rather it's having a good
process for weighing all the information
appropriately if you this is about the
end of my talk if you enjoyed it and
you're interested in more in-depth
pieces on the topic these are some great
reads much of that many of them were
kind of resources for forming this talk
and they do a far better job of kind of
explaining and covering this type of
stuff than i can i'll post these online
to github and i'll tweet them out later
for in case anyone wants to kind of
click through these links as well so
thank you very much if anyone has
questions or comments I be I'd love to
hear your thoughts on all of this